ah welcome playing baby bunny welcome to
this video portuguese flag but no name
no nothing Oh brand new account d phi if
this is a uncommon response to this to
this line of the dutch so what is he
doing really try and form for a pawn
okay well i can't play queen bee three
and just a Quincy to we have and queen
bee three as a very lame way to play it
so I'm just going to invent up here and
ask him what what exactly the plan is
with putting the Queen on b6 okay I'm
cd5 is is interesting because ed Queen
f5 might be on but if maybe can take on
between Queenie six check it's not a
maid so let's just develop
yeah that's a we had a form of a stone
wall where he has a little development
and the Queen on b6 is really have funny
piece I'm just going to develop him yeah
i was thinking about it but come on it
just castle really one wonder if he
wants to make fun of me or something
this kind of setup is really strange so
95 4f 3yo mmm is Knight e5 a bit too
this is a bit too pedestrian I can also
take this is actually an interesting way
to play for a very quick f3
um okay so queen bee three is
interesting let's let's start with this
night see for us what's the point that i
had but it's not it's not a realist this
is this is good for Wyatt but I was
thinking it should be even better it's
an it's a good-looking piece on d6 but
it's not so clear what it is doing
yeah so now FYI have to support the pawn
try to open up open up the position Jim
that it both looks good but rook takes
this may be more straightforward just
fun I mean I actually now have
recognized that she cannot easily attack
the pond I'm just in for Luke f1 and
winning the f5 bond that looks difficult
to prevent
guindy 7 but I mean 23 s which is just
one way to try it I can also try to
swing over like Queen you one things
like that also g4 is an idea the right
moment I don't I don't know I'm not sure
not sure if this is good midst and how I
got I don't know I don't know quite sure
how you can play this immediately but
okay he made many many far reaching
decisions immediately so why not this
one okay three two FYI guess then we age
three rock chicks edge form
it's still it's still fairly solid yeah
what what does this black position
whatever you can say about it it's still
fairly solid so taking it it takes you
have the beef file for look p1 and
things like that is so is somewhat is
somewhat effector but still I should
have played that quick on how to how to
avoid the same so just take a five or
not well I take a five look f8
I've time I got my pawn structure
repaired again rook age six would have
been good too right look see to what's
not necessary i just wanted to cover
this in advance but Brooke age six was
was a much stronger move check this is
not leading to much the checks
40 dem seconds now you can also give
checks on b1 and b2 or any ayah no DS or
for counter player jack will have been
all so awful
I can just take you six I mean losing
this game is a shame how would how bad
did I play that one white resigns from
this joke of an opening it's really a
complete joke here why does ah come on
this is this is really really bad so how
did I screw this up in this position is
just fantastic I can just take h4 yeah I
thought I this is so convenient I can do
whatever I want really but it's not the
case it's really not the case i can i
can take here because Queenie 5 this is
this is just lost that this is the
problem this is hanging and here the
queen is gone so yeah then then this is
this is basically over right again I can
take here now for for this yeah okay but
this is this is really not winning this
is quite amazing with b6 and after that
I'm going after before it's that's very
very very hard very hard to to accept
after Queen g4 I'm better again yeah I
mean here here white is definitely
better but how did ask I mean Luke c2
was a complete bogus move I was afraid
of rooks rook be one Luke see one that
the sea porn would forward this is this
is not Luke edge to as much better
whoops it's really much better I look
age 6 what I later thought but rock G
sixes sort of at least keeping things
together I mean this is all like if you
give the computer evil as +1 something
although thought of the time but I still
felt he should should should be over for
a long time this is this is really not
clear at all and absolutely not jack
jessee's now invading sham and that this
was good for him and mrs. quite amazing
but isn't there some way the night on
the six is a funny p is it looks good
but now by now it's not doing anything I
really have a hard time to get it back
into plain and this is what I tried with
98 some of this this but it's not not
doing not doing anything I probably have
to maybe this kind of way why a five but
this is already problematic the deep
porn and I don't really know look at
this
Jim the comp gives us as a drawn just
just about a draw very difficult though
here everything has shifted yeah i mean
i really don't know i mean even this
year see if I've was never possible to
refute this nonsense right I mean I'm
sorry yeah this kind of thing with
nonsense and so on this is nonsensical
the move Queen B 6 does not belong in
this position ever neither does g6
belonging to this is me it just leads to
an overwhelmingly good position for wide
but somehow somehow it may be Bishop
before I mean look at white is
completely developed yeah I've got
everything out he's got a rotten porn
structure and he's moved the Queen like
three times without any purpose so it
should be really something substantial
of course the position is closed what I
didn't really appreciate is that he can
take with the deep on I was thinking he
has to check with this and my idea was
to play a quick f3 here to open up the
position that he cannot even castle but
d takes is some it's maybe just just the
better the better way to play it and now
now with hindsight this is also not the
best move I should probably trade now
Bishop takes and now Bishop b5 or I can
Oh Bishop d6 this is also better better
than the game this takes very nice
control well the bishop now is really
bad and any e5 trades the dark squared
bishop so yeah this this is this is a
very convincing way for why to keep a
long-term edge where you just have a
very comfortable long-term position and
advantage the way it went I mean I also
had that but this was even more even
clearer let's say
and by the way why don't I just take
this pawn this was also possibly with
the bishop looking at b8 there's no
rugby aid sometimes it makes sense to to
do a little bit of concrete calculation
I mean I was only thinking about about
this structure which is also good but
just taking this point for nothing would
have been would have been very
convincing I guess okay thanks for
watching